Pharrell Williams announces July 4th is
cancelled corporations pulled their
money from social media at the behest of
the leftist sensors and kovat 19 cases
continued to rise but hospitals aren't
overwhelmed I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show this show is sponsored
by expressvpn stop putting your online
data at risk get protected at expressvpn
tom / ben so remember when this whole
thing was about trying to put together
solutions for instances of police
brutality remember was about better
policing and now it has nothing to do
with better policing now it is just
about virtue signaling largely by white
woke leftists who oddly enough have
decided that they are the most important
people on planet earth now that is a
natural outgrowth of the sort of
philosophy promulgated by Robyn D'Angelo
and her crappy book white fragility I
have a brand new YouTube video you
should go check out about white
fragility it's 30 minutes of hate about
fragility the book is just terrible
but the entire thesis of the book is the
only important people on planet earth
are white walk liberals they're the only
people who are important because they
are the ones who control the systems and
are come in the systems and so if they
do not fight back against the systems of
power and the hierarchies of power well
then they are letting down black
Americans and black Americans are robbed
of all agency in Robins angela's world
and this means that white liberals might
even have to be a little paternalistic
for black people well you can see all of
this on display in a video that was
going around Twitter yesterday there's a
man of color who is going to a a fence
in his neighborhood that is covered top
to bottom with sort of black lives
matter propaganda and he's taking down
the signs because he lives across the
sea the street and he says I'm sick of
looking at his fence covered with signs
right now huh and a young white man and
proceeds to try and tackle him comes
charging down the street and starts
screaming at him and explaining to him
he has not woken up so that this I think
fairly encapsulate how America is
working these days is the same thing as
the white yoga pants wearing Lululemon
moms young moms are screaming at black
cops in New York City and Washington DC
this idea that the white walk whether
they have come for all of us and that if
they do not listen if they do not listen
if they take a perspective on America
that is different than the perspective
taken by black lives matter this means
that
unquote as I say this thing is extended
far beyond far beyond the idea of police
brutality or even disproportionate
police use of force which again there's
no evidence that police
disproportionately use deadly force on
black and Hispanic Americans according
to Roland fryer there is some evidence
that police may use disproportionate
force in low-level force situations so
for example patting people down or
grabbing somebody during a police
encounter but it's very difficult to
control for that because you don't know
exactly how people are interacting with
the police or what prompted that but
that's what Roland fryer study says but
the idea that black people are
overwhelmingly being shot by the police
or the police are overwhelmingly
systemically racist or that they are
stopping people for driving solely
because of the color of their skin as
opposed to how they are driving the
evidence for that is incredibly scanty
but the narrative has moved from from
that to the more broad application of
the court unquote anti-racist narrative
and as I discussed yesterday
the very term racist has now been
redefined so Abram Kensie who is most
famously associated with this
neo-marxist notion of anti racism that
has been redefined so anti racism is the
basic idea that if you if you do not
oppose the promulgated systems of the
United States if you do not oppose the
declaration the Constitution of the
United States capitalism then you are
then you are complicit in racism you're
part of the problem right there's just
racist and anti-racist there is no such
thing as not racist because racist used
to mean you believe that one race is
inherently superior to another and if
you don't believe that you're not a
racist but now racism has been redefined
it's you mean any system that results in
inequality between outcomes for groups
must be a systemic a systemically
discriminating system and therefore if
you stand for any of those systems
you yourself are discriminatory and you
are complicit in white privilege and you
are complicit in whiteness right that is
the theory of even Kensie it makes no
sense obviously because the fact is that
Asians and white people don't have the
same level of incomes that mean that the
systems were built for Asians that the
inequality of outcome means inequity
designed by a privileged hierarchy in
the United States of course that's now
it means but the Improv Mackenzie idea
is if you don't oppose the systems then
the systems themselves are the root of
the inequality they're the root of all
inequality and the systems must be torn
down and this means that anything that
has to do with the systems has to be
torn down and this is how you
ends up with somebody like Pharrell
Williams suggesting that July 4th is bad
right so Pharrell Williams is of course
an incredibly famous and successful
singer songwriter and music executive
this is not somebody who has led a
radically difficult life in the United
States by all indicators he's led a
pretty great life in the United States
this person is probably worth hundreds
of millions of dollars at a minimum this
is a person who was born in Virginia
Beach Virginia and he has a couple of
brothers his mom was a teacher his dad
was a handyman
he went to seventh grade at summer band
camp and then he ended up at
Northwestern University for a couple of
years this does not sound like the story
of Wilde unsuccess that supposedly
America is is fostering it does not
sound like the story of discrimination
and evil that America is fostering but
according to Pharrell Williams Pharrell
Williams says that July 4th is really
really bad and this is a very bizarre
view of July 4th because as you will see
the great black liberators in American
history particularly people like
Frederick Frederick Douglass understood
that July 4th originally did not apply
to slaves Rachel he have a very very
famous oration a very hard-nosed and
edgy oration did Frederick Douglass
before slavery was abolished in which he
talked about the fact that your life was
not applied to black Americans the black
Americans looked at July 4th they said
it's not our holiday we're still in
slavery and liberated you but it didn't
liberate us but he said the point is
that July 4th is the ideal to which you
guys need to be held July 4th is the
standard that you will be held to Martin
Luther King jr. said the same thing but
the new brand of black leadership is to
suggest that July 4th is inherently evil
that the end of slavery the end of Jim
Crow none of that means anything and so
July 4th itself needs to be cancelled
because basically America needs to be
cancelled it is not that America was
built on high ideals that people fail to
live up to
it's that America's ideals were the
founding Creed of racism sexism bigotry
and homophobia the system's themselves
created racism er this case the
different Kennedy actually makes
explicitly right that the systems
themselves created racism racism was was
not even the progenitor of the systems
the systems created racism and then
those systems are still in place today
and therefore nothing has changed and
therefore the system's need to be ripped
down and so you can have people like
Pharrell Williams or incredibly
successful within the system or fighting
the system because the system itself is
the racism
system doesn't have to be shown to be
racist the system doesn't you don't have
to look at the system and say here's a
racist thing about the system instead
all you have to do even if you're
Pharrell Williams and you're a very very
wealthy black man in America who's
letting incredibly successful and
blessed life in the United States you
can still look at the group inequality
data and say this system is unfair and
bad and therefore July 4th has to go
we're gonna get to Pharrell Williams and
where this idea comes from in just one
second
first let's be real about this you
shouldn't assume that your monthly cell
phone bill is a forever thing okay
you're spending way too much money on
your monthly cell phone bill it should
be less than it is now I'm particularly
right now and people are looking to save
money because who the hell knows where
the economy is you should be looking at
pure talk USA with pure talk USA you can
cut costs and free up cash on a monthly
basis starting with your wireless
provider pure talk covers ninety-nine
percent of Americans the president and
CEO of pure talk is u.s. veteran who
cares deeply about serving Americans by
making wireless affordable start your
saving today there is no reason why you
should be spending a fortune on your
cell phone bill I mean the pure talk is
making it super easy for you to save
money here's how it works
dial pound two fifty and say key word
ben shapiro and yet unlimited talk
unlimited text two gigs of data for
twenty bucks a month not a hundred bucks
a month now two hundred some month
twenty bucks a month again dial palin
250 say key word ben shapiro you get
unlimited talk unlimited text two gigs
of data plus he had 50% on four first
month so it's ten bucks your first month
stop paying too much too big wireless
providers by the way the coverage is
stellar switch to pure talk today save
fifty percent off your first month dial
palin 250 say key word Bennett Shapiro
pure talk USA simply smarter Wireless go
check them out right now and save
yourself a bundle on your cell phone
bill dial palin 250 say key word ben
shapiro to get started okay so Pharrell
Williams does this interview on CNBC and
he criticizes Independence Day and then
he advocates for reparations he also
suggests that we take off Juneteenth as
a paid holiday which by the way I don't
have really a problem with a Juneteenth
seems like that should be a day of
American celebration that is the day on
which the Emancipation Proclamation was
finally read to the freed slaves of
Texas which was the last States to read
the Emancipation Proclamation they have
in June 19th 1865
so that that is a that is a day well
worth celebrating and by the way the
reason it's worth celebrating is because
it marked eight an actual shift in
American history a shift that so many of
the folks of the woke left refused to
acknowledge
because slavery according to the web
left merely one underground right
slavery never really ended it just
became according to Anna duverney a
system of prison industrial complexes it
simply became according to Robyn
D'Angelo the soft bigotry of the regular
corporate world and all of this sort of
nonsense the reason we should celebrate
Juneteenth is because it was in fact a
sea change and it was a living up to
ideals so here is Pharrell Williams
ignoring all of that and suggesting
instead that Independence Day is is
really bad and therefore and therefore
it shouldn't really be a national it's
not really a national holiday for
everyone when July 4 1776 took place the
only ones that were free from the
British monarchy where were our white
brothers when you think about June 18th
you know that marks a two-year period
where we were supposed to be free but we
hadn't been still we feel like the day
that we were freed everyone was free so
why not make that a paid holiday we
deserve that
you know there's a word that scares so
many people you know it's called
reparations and we deserved that too
okay I don't understand how all ends
with two hundred million dollars
deserves reparations from a white
Appalachian guy who's worth $20,000 or
zero or a zero that doesn't make any
sense to me
now to be fair to Pharrell Williams he's
suggesting again Juneteenth in addition
to July 4th okay and that again I don't
actually have a problem with but the
criticism of July 4th ceased to apply
when Juneteenth happen okay the
criticism of July 4th became irrelevant
by the terms of the deal what I mean by
that is that July 4th was an
aspirational holiday about American
freedom and Frederick Douglass
criticized July 4th in really strong
language right because he said that
you're not living up to your own
founding Creed but July 4th is a day of
celebration for everyone the suggestion
by Pharrell Williams that is not a
celebration for everyone today
is obviously very silly it is a day of
celebration for everyone because it does
represent the key points in the
liberation of all Americans it just took
far longer because of cruelty and evil
for black Americans to gain the freedoms
that should have been promised in them
on July 4th here's what Frederick
Douglass who has a lot more it seems to
me the Federalist had a lot more to say
about the problems of racism and big
trait and cruelty of racism and anybody
who's alive today
I mean Frederick Douglass actually lived
as a slave right here's here's Frederick
Douglass talking about to give very
famous oration on this and it's a
beautiful beautiful piece of both
writing and oratory very famous it's one
of the reasons why I've suggested that
Frederick Douglass is a second founding
father who should be formed on the
American currency because he along with
Abraham Lincoln really understood that
the Declaration of Independence in the
Constitution of the United States where
ideals to aspire to an America was not
living up to those ideals and they had
to be brought into balance right they
had to be brought into rectification
because according to a lot of people the
Declaration of Independence in the
Constitution were in opposition to one
another in fact Chauncey Calhoun who was
one of the leaders of the sort of pre
Confederacy Confederacy right he died
before the actual Civil War but he was a
he was an ardent pro-slavery advocate he
suggested the Declaration of
Independence was bad but the only thing
that mattered was the Constitution where
as Abraham Lincoln suggested that the
Declaration of Independence is what he
called the apple of gold and the
Constitution the frame of silver what he
meant by that is the ideals of the
Declaration of Independence were
protected by the Constitution so if you
read the Constitution without the
Declaration and you would miss the high
ideals which are the reasons that the
Constitution was brought about in the
first place and again slaveholders said
okay well his equitation doesn't matter
that was just kind of something we said
I'm there's something that we just put
out there's a piece of propaganda the
only thing that matters is the hard
terms of the Constitution the reason the
Declaration of Independence matters and
that's what we're celebrating on July
4th right that's not Constitution Day
that's July 4th the reason we celebrate
the Declaration of Independence is
because the philosophy of the United
States is embedded in the Declaration of
Independence really three separate
propositions first the reality of
natural rights pre-existing government
inalienable and precious and endemic to
all human beings right natural rights
that exist for you no matter where you
are right not equally realize for
everybody at all times but those natural
rights pre-exists government second the
Equality of all human beings before the
law and in their rights all men are
created equal right that doesn't mean
all men are created with equal capacity
or equal ability it means that all men
are to be treated the same by the law
because you are equal in your rights
those rights that pre-exists government
and finally the belief that government
exists to protect natural rights and to
enforce that equality before law that's
the role of government that's what the
Declaration of Independence is about
American philosophy believes these
propositions are self-evident
right and then the founders attempted to
effectuate that philosophy in the
Constitution of the United States and
that's what Frederick Douglass
recognized in a way that so many of
today's modern race thinkers refuse to
recognize Frederick Douglass said look
the obstacle here is racism the obstacle
is old-fashioned brutal bigotry you know
the obstacle here is slavery and Jim
Crow and institutions of discrimination
and remove those and what you are left
with is again that gold Apple in the
silver frame but according to so many
thinkers today that's not really the
problem there was no gold Apple the gold
Apple was always warm ridden and the
silver frame was always made of dross
right that's the actual argument here is
whether the declaration in the
Constitution are inherently good or
whether the declaration of and
constitutionally corrupt and evil
Frederick Douglass said they're
inherently good we're not living up to
them here's what Frederick Douglass a
freed slave who let me tell you has
suffered a hell of a lot more and
Pharrell Williams ever has in his life
and that is not a close comparison by
the way fair to say Frederick Douglass
suffered a hell of a lot more than
virtually every person living in America
the man lived as a slave here's what he
says the signers of the Declaration of
Independence were brave men they were
great men too great enough to give Fame
to a great age they believed in order
but not in the order of tyranny with
them and nothing was settled that was
not right with them justice liberty and
humanity were final not slavery and
oppression but he sayings that the
principles they established would allow
for the extirpation of slavery and
oppression and the question he asked
this was a big question in his July 4th
peroration he said are the great
principles of political freedom and of
natural justice embodied in that
Declaration of Independence extended to
us right the entire the entire thing is
I'm not ripping on the Declaration I'm
not ripping on the Constitution I'm not
even ripping on the founders what I am
saying is what Frederick Douglass says
is those when these words were written
they were not true for us but we need to
make them true for us because they are
great principles of political freedom
and of natural justice
what exactly are those great principles
so Calvin Coolidge probably the most
underrated president in American history
Pavin coach was a very good president he
have the one hundred and fiftieth
anniversary speech in 1926 about the
about the Declaration of Independence
and here is how he described the
philosophy of the Declaration of
Independence he said if all men are
created equal that is final if they are
endowed with inalienable rights that is
final if governments derive their just
powers from the consent of the governed
that is final no advance no progress
can't
made beyond these propositions if anyone
wishes to deny their truth or their
soundness the only direction in which he
can't proceed historically is not
forward but backward for at the time
when there was no equality no rights of
the individual no rule of the people we
live in an age of science and of
abounding accumulation of material
things these did not create our
declaration our declaration created them
that's what we're celebrating on July
4th and that's something that all
Americans should be celebrating this
weekend as we approach July 4th but
unfortunately there is a case of foot do
not celebrate those things because in
the view again of so many of the
disintegration as since I described in
my upcoming book how to destroy America
in three easy steps in the book I
describe people who want to disintegrate
the union is disintegration us it's not
right versus left its disintegration is
versus unionist people who'd like to see
the country held together on the basis
of fundamental principles and people who
would like to see the country
fall apart maybe the basic idea that
those principles are themselves rooted
in sexism and bigotry and racism and
have promulgated sexist and bigotry
racism inequality that's a battle for
the heart and soul of the country that
is a battle for the for the entire mind
and future of the country and as a
battle whether we are going to go
forward or whether we're gonna go
backward because Coolidge was exactly
right progress progress what what made
America unique what makes America
powerful what makes America good are the
original founding principles we have so
often failed to live up to but that we
have always striven to move toward as a
country not everybody in the country but
the country as a whole and that we've
always we've tried to move toward that
stumbling falling by overall moving
toward that progress and if you move
away from those fundamental principles
and that's what we're talking about
right now destruction of those
fundamental principles right that all
men are created equal and endowed with
inalienable rights and that governments
derive their just powers from the
consent of the governed as we move away
from that we move toward regression not
progression we move toward either mob
rule or autocracy right that is what we
move toward not freedom not liberty not
not prosperity all those things become a
figment of the imagination and this is
and by the way the disintegrations are
fighting all of these principles right
now the notion that all men are created
equal is something that is denied it is
fundamentally denied by the white
fragility anti racism a lack of bedroom
candy and end of end of Robins Angelou
because again you can judge someone and
their complicity in this
simply on the basis of their race if
that denies it doesn't it doesn't
actually acknowledge that all men are
created equal in their rights what they
do is they play a little word game they
say what we mean by all men are created
equal is that if all men are truly
created equal this is what this is
basically what what Abram Kenny says if
all men are truly created equal they
should all have equal outcomes that's
not what all men are created equal means
all men are created equal means they
were created with rights they were
created equal before the law it doesn't
mean that Colton and I both have the
same jump shot it doesn't mean and I'm
gonna play in the NBA or be a double w/e
wrestler or that somebody else is
capable of hosting a successful podcast
we all have different abilities that's
called being a human being what it does
mean is that in the eyes of God in the
eyes of the law we are all equal the
notion that we're in tad with
inalienable rights the left doesn't
believe in inalienable rights so what
believes like the French Revolution
believed that rights can be put aside in
favor of the of the common good right
the idea is the common good can
overreach those rights and so this is
why you are seeing right now and
attacked particularly on freedom of
speech which we'll get to in just one
second the the idea that governments
derive their just powers from the
consent of the governed that too is is
overwritten instead the left would love
to see mob rule because what we're
seeing right now has nothing to do with
the consent of the governed is Chaz
about the consent of the governed and
left is running for it is it is pure
majoritarianism the consent of the
governed because who consents to be
governed by a pure 51% majority nobody
right your your inalienable rights
cannot be alienated by that by a simple
majority vote the founders understood
this but all of these things are being
disintegrated in the name of a new
utopia and that's really terrible July
4th has to stand because July 4th is
really really important instead we seems
to be moving away from the principles of
July 4th by grouping people together in
races by moving away from the principles
of Juneteenth by the way by moving away
from the principles of Frederick
Douglass and Abraham Lincoln and yes the
principles of the Declaration in the
Constitution and that's a disaster for
the country well get some more of this
in just one second first let's talk
about the fact that these days with
everybody having stuff delivered to
their home one of the big problems that
we've been seeing in our neighborhood is
people stopping by your front door and
just taking the packages and running
people driving up to your mailbox
opening up the mailbox
stealing your amazon stuff and then just
take it off well you know how you can
stop this and you can help
you could have ring what happened well
ring is on a mission to make
neighborhood safer their home security
products are designed to give you peace
of mind around the clock you can keep
track of what's going on on your
property any time of the day anywhere
you happen to be on planet earth at the
time their home security products video
doorbell security cameras smart security
lighting alarm systems ring has
everything you need to make sure that
your family and belongings are safe and
secure anytime anywhere and with the all
new ring video doorbell 3 you can keep
an even closer eye on things and ever
before ring gives you protection at
every corner video doorbells let you
answer the door and check in on your
home anytime keep an eye on your
doorstep or speak to delivery people
when you can't come to the door without
door security cameras you can check in
on every part of your house and never
miss a moment smart lighting right in
some blind spots and make sure that you
can always come home to a brightly lit
house their full home security systems
give you everything you need to protect
your family and your pets and your
property got a special offer on the ring
welcome kit when you go to ring calm /
Ben and that's ringing calm / Ben
welcome kit includes that ring video
doorbell 3 and the chime pro it's all
you need to start building custom
security for your home today but ring
calm / Ben again that is ring calm / Ben
ring calm / Ben go check them out right
now ok so the media are complicit in
this attempts to destroy basic American
ideals and divide us as much as humanly
possible the New York Times has decided
for example that they are simply going
to change the language so just like we
are now changing the definition of
racism so that racism doesn't mean
belief in superiority or inferiority of
a particular race racism is now instead
going to mean you're complicit in the
systems that produce inequality right
that is the that is the basic definition
of racism now now we are going to shift
the definitions of race in a bizarre way
as well so now apparently the New York
Times is going to use the uppercase
black to describe people and cultures of
African origin both in the United States
and elsewhere according to the United
States according to the New York Times
we believe this style best conveys
elements of shared history and identity
and reflects our goal to be respectful
about all the people and communities we
cover the change will match what many
readers are seeing elsewhere The
Associated Press and other major news
organizations have recently adopted
black what capital B which has long been
favored by many African American
publications and other outlets the new
style is also consistent with our
treatment of many other racial and
ethnic terms we recently decided to
capitalize native and indigenous while
other ethnic terms like Asian American
and Latino
been capitalised will retain lowercase
treatment for white well there's an
obvious question of parallelism
there's been no comparable movement
toward widespread adoption of a new
style for white and there's less of a
sense that white describes a shared
culture and history again this goes back
to the I keep quoting white fertility
because that's where this crap is coming
from the basic idea here is that
whiteness only exists in opposition to
blackness there's no such thing as a
white identity there's only a cohesive
black identity well you're gonna have to
explain that one to me seriously because
you're gonna have to explain to me why a
person from Haiti and a person from
Zimbabwe have the same cultural heritage
and history as they have the same and so
they deserve to be capitalized as
capital B black they're part of the same
cultural and ethnic history but a guy
from Austria and a guy from Germany nine
miles apart who are both white they sure
know common ethnic heritage none
according to this I mean it's just it's
ridiculous obviously the basic idea
instead is that whiteness is bad
blackness is good because blackness is
an identity white can only exist in
opposition to blackness and therefore
whiteness is truly about racism right
this is a word that you will see very
often in the in the woke literature is
whiteness whiteness as a descriptor of
badness right you have internalized your
whiteness if you integrate into the
systems you are internalizing your
whiteness this is how they can call
people like Clarence Thomas in Oreo
because the idea is that he's
internalized his whiteness or he's a
black man but he's white on the inside
cause he's internalized his whiteness by
the way this is sort of the premise of
the of the it's unbeliev movie really
was not perceived as how racist it is
the movie get out is really about this
right the idea of get out is a black man
who's being treated incredibly well by a
white family and then of course it turns
out to be a horror story about them
attempting to capture his body and then
turn him into a white person on the
inside right they literally want to take
his body and then take their white souls
and put them in his black body to take
control of his body right the this
notion that whiteness is the threat
because whiteness only exists in
opposition to blackness the only thing
that brings white people together is
being in opposition to black people is
white it's quite a linguistic twist but
this is the way that we are going to buy
the country and make the country worse
and worse that that is the direction in
which we're moving okay in just a second
we're gonna get to the funniest story of
the day because things are getting wild
over at Chaz in Seattle we're also gonna
get back into the social media wars
because it is pretty obvious right now
that the entire wolf mentality that says
that
the hallmarks of your culture of rights
needs to be disintegrated if they're not
disintegrated and you are exacerbating
inequality I will get to that in just
one second plus well gets your Co bit
updates a lot coming up first you know
my family it is growing and that means
that it is time to get a new portrait
from paint your life calm so my family
we have a new child we already have a
portrait that's hanging over our mantel
it is just beautiful
it is just beautiful okay it is a
picture of me and my wife were on a
beach in Hawaii with our with our two
children at the time now we need to
update it we need our little tiny two
baby she's the best baby in the entire
world oh she's just a cutie she kept me
up half the night last night but we love
her anyway
and we need her in a portrait because
paint your life to pin your life is
great here's what happens you get a
professional hand-painted portrait
created from any photo at a truly
affordable price it can choose from a
team of world-class artists and work
with them until every detail is perfect
their user-friendly platform once you
order a custom-made
hand-painted portrait in less than 5
minutes it's quick and easy get a hand
painted portrait in about three weeks
you can send any picture they give me
anything and they will paint it for you
it makes the perfect birthday
anniversary or Father's Day gift it's
meaningful personal personal and can be
cherished forever it makes a great gift
for your parents by the way like a great
gift for your parents at paint your life
calm there is no risk if you don't love
the final painting and your money is
refunded guaranteed right now is limited
time offer it get 20% off your painting
that's correct
20% off and free shipping to get the
special offer text the word been to
64,000 that's been to 64,000 just six
been at 64,000 you get 20% off and free
shipping it is an amazing amazing gift
paint your life calm expense you 64000
celebrate the moments that matter most
it is amazing amazing that stuff okay
meanwhile this is the best story of the
day out of Seattle and it does
demonstrate how the media are willing to
go along with violence so long is that
violence see just that the system is bad
and the system is racist so in Seattle
they've had this idiotic Chazz chopped
dangerous place from had several
shootings having four shootings in Chas
chopped since the police were forced out
and mayor Jennings turrican called it a
street fair and she said that it was
just a wonderful wonderful place well
the chickens finally came home to roost
because it turns out that Shama saw one
who's a nut okay Shama someone is a
socialist City Councilwoman in Seattle I
know Councilwoman Salomon I debated her
when I was on and when I had a a
specific local show on Katie th one of
our affiliates here on the bench Shapiro
shop and
we debated $15 minimum wage you should
watch it it's quite entertaining
but Thomas I want led a led a rally
outside of Jenny Perkins home and now
Jenny zerkin is calling for Chama salons
to be punished or expelled from the City
Council for doing that why she wrote a
letter to the council president is mayor
Jenny zerkin so Jenny Durkin is
perfectly willing to allow fully
law-abiding areas of the city to fall
victims to anarchy and she's allowed to
she'sshe's gonna just allow people to
get shot willy-nilly and as part of the
city but somebody marched outside her
house that means it's time to fire the
City Council the City Council woman
short a letter saying the city's
residents and businesses expect us to
work on many important issues together
including unprecedented challenges such
as a global pandemic we're sending in
our city an economic downturn that could
become the worst economic event in our
city's history and a civil rights
movement in our streets the public
deserves to see their government working
together to resolve differences and face
these challenges article 4 section 4
provides the council may punish or expel
a member or disorderly or otherwise
contemptuous behavior some of these
violations may be additional violations
of the Seattle ethics and elections
committee but all of these fall within
the City Council's purview so she's
going after Thomas Allen why is she
going after Thomas Allen because she
helped people illegally occupied city
property which by the way Jennings Arkin
praised at the time right she she
encouraged people to do this in the
middle of pandemic and quote she used
her official positions to lead a march
to my home despite the fact it was
publicly known I was not there and she
and organizers knew my address was
protected under the state convey
confidentiality program because of
threats against me due largely to my
work as US Attorney all of us have
joined hundreds of demonstrations across
the city the councilmember silent and
her followers chose to do so with
reckless disregard of the safety of my
family and children in addition during
her after council members how long
speeches that rally her followers
vandalized my home by spray-painting
obscenities oh well it seems what the
chickens came home to roost for the
mayor and now she wants Shama cell long
con now she's blaming Shama cell on for
all of this why it's just amazing it
seems like when liberals get mugged by
reality suddenly they're not so fond of
their Chaz chop New Republic beautiful
utopia's anymore it's pretty incredible
but the media will go along with this
nonsense and me you'll go along with
people who are threatening other people
and defacing property and break me into
private
property block of wood Chris Cuomo over
on CNN he tried this routine last night
so he had on the mail from the famous
couple the so-called Kenan Caron couple
from Missouri
this was he's a lawyer in the area is
Mark McCluskey and he was he came out of
his house with his wife when the
situation was when black lives matter
protesters broke into a private gated
community and walked down the street and
there were some pretty cellar pictures
of him walking out of the out of his
house carrying in air 15 and his wife
had a small pistol in her hand and she's
shouting at the protesters and it turns
out that according to him the protesters
were threatening to burn down his house
and do property damage okay so Chris
Cuomo has them on his show last night
and Chris Cuomo's first question his
questions are like why would you do such
an evil thing is to defend your house
why are you defending your house it's
really bad you need to stop defending
your house cut it out and Martin klasky
was like it's my house and the reason
they didn't burn is because I was out
there with a gun I understand what you
say your rationale was to be clear did
anything happen to you or your property
do you think happen yeah my my life has
been ruined I know I will get to that
mr. McClosky I don't mean to cut you off
but I'm saying that night did anything
happen to you your family or your
property
yeah it's called social intimidation
it's called terrorism Chris watch the
definition of terrorism to use violence
and intimidation to frighten the public
that's what was happening that night
it's what happened to me and that's the
damage I've suffered okay so the bottom
line there is Chris and my favorite part
of that is Chris Cuomo suggesting so
nothing happened your house did it right
cuz you were standing out there with a
gun who's standing out there with a gun
but the bottom line is that once you
accept that all behavior individual bad
individual behavior is the result of the
system and the system is to blame July
4th is to blame right once the entire
system is to blame for all the bad
things and you can't blame the
individual protest or shouting this guy
they're gonna burn his home you have to
blame the guy who's defending his home
because after all his home is property
and property is bad you have to
understand that his property is a
symptom of an unequal system and just
because the people protesting past his
house didn't have houses like that that
means that they are the victims of the
system whereas he himself is actually
the perpetrator of this evil in unequal
that is the nonsense that the left is
pushing now if anybody ever came up to
Chris Cuomo's house would be a different
story right did anybody ever calls Chris
Cuomo afraid oh for goodness sake then
they are then it's like the the n-word
apparently if you use if use Fredo
according to Chris Cuomo so apparently
he's allowed to take great offense at
people saying innocuous things like
calling him the dumb brother from from
the Godfather but he but if somebody
threatens to burn your house you're
supposed to just sit inside and wait on
it it would get to more of this in just
one second we'll get to the crusade
against social media which again is
being ramped up in real time first let
us talk about the fact that if you are a
small business and you have to send
invoices it can be a giant pain in the
butt so let's say that you are a small
business and you got ten invoices
outstanding so you go over to Microsoft
Word you type up the invoices you send
them out and then you completely forgot
these on them if no update if no idea
where the person has seen it you have no
idea you know how if you even have to
follow up also this done in Microsoft
words hole looks super ugly instead why
don't you just go use blink sale right
now our friends at bling sale small
business owners themselves built an
invoicing software that helps you stay
on top of your money and keep track of
track of everything in one place you can
stop sending nagging emails to get paid
for your work instead you can get back
to growing your business with bling sale
you can send beautiful custom branded
invoices and estimates in seconds you
can stay on top of your outstanding
invoices it Alette your customers and
clients easily pay your invoices online
you'll even get instant notifications
when a customer opens your invoice so
actually know if they're just avoiding
paying you forget about using invoice
templates or stressing about
coordinating a bunch of different
software programs link sale will take
care of all of it so you can spend more
time focusing on the work it actually
gets you paid and makes your business a
success
go check out bling sale right now it
will make your life better and easier
it'll make your clients lives better and
easier because they'll be getting
invoices that are actually readable not
just a scan of some word document you
print it off see for yourself trembling
sale for free @ bling sale com / pen at
is bli NK s al e comm / pen it's bling
sale calm / men and traveling sale for
free right now spend less time billing
more time at doing the things that you
love already in just a second we're
going to get again the attacks on social
media which is the attempt to shut down
rights as a symptom of the evil system
we'll get to that momentarily first if
you're not already to tell you I
remember you should consider getting a
reader's pass to daily wire.com it's a
great value only three bucks a month
when you sign up you get that first
for only 99 cents you also go to act
access to our mobile app articles have
free access to exclusive editorials like
Matt Walsh's new editorial activist once
imagined to be our new anthem it is the
worst song ever written
okay that is not even an op-ed that is
just a fact-based journalistic piece
imagine is indeed the worst song ever
written if you want to find out why from
Matt Walsh and sardonic perspective go
check out our readers pass right now at
daily wire.com and sign up for just a
dolla go check it out daily where icon
sign up for just one dollar also as I
mentioned before I like I don't pitch my
work this way it is so vital and
important and an immediate that you
really do need to pick up a copy of my
new book early how to destroy America in
three easy steps it comes out July 21st
it is so topical it's so OnPoint all the
things that are happening right now
I prophesied back when I wrote this
thing in December and January and I can
tell you it is it is so relevant and
it's not just relevant to diagnose our
problems it is relevant to talk about
the solutions give you the responses
that you need when you're discussing
these issues with friends around the
water cooler I think it is maybe the
most important book I've ever written I
wrote right side of history which i
think is a deeply deeply important book
go check out the new book how to destroy
America in three easy steps at daily
wire.com /ban you can pre-order right
now it is out July 21st I'll be the
first to read it
check it out daily wire.com slash man
you're listening to the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast and radio
show in the nation
[Music]
so there's a concerted effort right now
by the politically by the politically
Machiavellian and by the whoa to unite
in an attempt to use social media to
crack down on messages they don't like
that is the the latest iteration so
woken is is being used as an excuse to
blackmail social media companies into
reinstituting a monopoly on
informational dissemination what that
means is that it used to be you only got
your information from CBS NBC ABC in New
York Times Washington Post that was
basically everything then the internet
comes about thank God and the internet
led by people like Matt Raj really opens
everything up right they really open up
the dissemination of information now you
can go to daily wire and you can get a
more accurate take on the news from a
conservative perspective now you can
head on over to Drudge and you can check
all the headlines from drudges perspect
you can go all over the internet and get
well you can go to Daily Caller and
check out their news foundation which
does a great job you can do all of these
things right and that's great you can
check out the Federalist lots of friends
on the right and we hope all of them do
really well and you can check all of
them right it's what the Internet does
it allows for broader dissemination of
information you can watch Fox News now
which is great because now you're no
longer relegated to CNN or just MSNBC
and that's a wonderful thing but the
problem is that the media likes being
the gatekeeper for information the media
loves being the gatekeeper for
information the problem was they never
had a great response to ok freedom of
speech right the response was freedom of
speech freedom of speech is great more
information is better aren't you the
ones who used to proclaim that you would
die for everybody else's right to say
something you disagreed with that was
literally the slogan of the ACLU
basically right we may disagree but I'll
I'll die for your right to say it so the
left had to come up with a new rationale
for why exactly they should reinstitute
a monopoly on informational
dissemination the new rationale is the
woken us crusade and the woke this
crusade is your dissemination of
information damages me freedom of speech
does not fall equally on the on
everybody freedom of speech is actually
a reinstitution of the hierarchy freedom
of speech is inherently threatening I
mentioned Herbert Marcuse a couple days
ago to reiterate the point is a
Frankfurt School professor from the
1960s very important thinker and Herbert
Marcuse promulgated an idea called what
he called repressive tolerance and when
he suggested was the problem is if you
tolerate bad opinions those opinions
might in fact increase intolerance so
instead what you have to do is you have
to stop
for bad opinions and you have to only
tolerate good opinions which normally
would call censorship right normally we
would just call that tyranny but he says
no no that's that's repressive tolerance
in order for tolerance to flourish in
order for the correct perspectives to
flourish what we really have to do is
shut down freedom of speech and this is
what you are seeing right now from the
walk left it went after the media it
went after corporations and corporations
are the big leverage point right now so
they're using corporations to go after
social media platforms now social media
platforms their original mandate was
their platform you can have debates you
can have open conversations they can
they can be rough it can be in their in
their sort of incipient form but at
least you're having a conversation that
is a good thing more information is
better information right this was sort
of the model of social media then the
woke left decided to go to the
corporation's which are responsible for
a lot of the advertising on these
platforms and say well do you stand with
the worst do you stand with the worst
people and now this has always been a
dishonest trick it's really been
dishonest so this is a trick the left
always loves to use with regard to a
variety of topics so I've said before I
believe in freedom of association yeah I
do I think you should be able to
associate with whomever you want I may
not agree with how you choose to use
that freedom of association and I
believe you should be able to associate
with whomever you want I believe that if
you're in a restaurant you should be
able to have whoever you want in and not
let whoever you want in and that means
that bad people are gonna be able to
misuse that freedom but I think it's
important that people have that freedom
because I don't think government should
have the power to compel you to run your
business in any particular way I think
that if you if you are a a if you are an
advocate of gay marriage and somebody
walks in well you don't like I think you
have every right to say to that person I
don't want you in my business I think
really I do I think that and if I think
likewise that you're a Christian Baker
and somebody walks in and says I want
you to bake me a transgender celebration
cake the Baker has every right to say I
don't you know what I'm not gonna do it
I'm sorry no I'm not doing that freedom
of association matters I think it's an
important concept so what the left will
say is us what that really means is
you're standing up for bigotry no I'm
standing up for the possibility that my
perspective may not be the correct
perspective and the left used to
appreciate this you know why because the
leftist perspective used to be a
minority in America if the if the right
had been successful in limiting freedom
of speech there would be no gay rights
movement in the United States there
wouldn't be right if the social right
had been successful in the 1950s in
limiting freedom of speech from a legal
person
or even associated socio-cultural
perspective those conversations never
could have happened but now that the
left is in commanding position they are
seeking to shut down the the methods of
dissemination so that only their
messages can be heard and Democratic
senators are excited about this because
obviously one of the effects of this
will match us beats who shut down
the quote/unquote racist messages and
this is again the let's use the term
races to describe everything they don't
like things can be things you don't like
and still not be racist they've used
this in order to say okay basically we
just want democratic messages out there
this is why Mark Zuckerberg is coming
under so much fire over at Facebook
Zuckerberg is the only major social
media leader who has come out and
clearly expressed a perspective in favor
of American standards of free speech
it's not happened to you too but it's
not happened at Google it's not happened
to Twitter instead those platforms have
basically decided that they are going to
cave to the world left and they are just
going to decide that they are that they
are perfectly willing to mirror whatever
are the political priorities of the woke
left these days and they'll ban anybody
or target anybody who disagrees that's
that's the way that these social media
these social media companies are moving
in
so instead boycott groups have decided
to go after corporations which are
risk-averse and don't like boycotts and
tell them to pull their money from
Facebook and now Democratic senators are
getting on board where there's just a
blackmail program to re-establish a
monopoly of information that's all this
really is just a blackmail program from
Democratic legislature from Democratic
legislators and social activists going
after corporations as all this is it is
a simple blackmail program get limit the
information that you put out there or we
are going to either regulate you if
we're Democratic senators or we are
going to call for boycotts if we are if
we are the activist types according to
Bloomberg Facebook chief executive
officer Mark Zuckerberg faces demands
from Senate Democrats for answers about
hate groups on the platform at the same
time a growing number of companies are
pulling advertising from its sites over
harmful content I love that just the the
vague term harmful content no one ever
defines these terms less harmful content
exactly does that mean that you saw
something that offended you or does it
mean that somebody's calling for your
explicit killing like there seems to be
a little bit difference in the letter to
Zuckerberg on Tuesday three Democratic
senators questioned what they call the
companies quote lack of action to
prevent white supremacist groups from
using the platform as a recruitment and
organizational tool despite Facebook's
stated policies on hate speech senators
Warner Robert Menendez of New Jersey and
mazie Hirono of wife who's all three of
those senators we wrote that the nation
is undergoing a long overdue examination
of systemic racism but suggested
Facebook is failing to do its parts and
now they're using the anti-racist
crusade as a leverage point against
against Facebook all by the way every
major executive which is a donor to the
Democratic Party well Facebook has
attempted to publicly align itself with
this movement its failure to address the
hate spreading on its platform reveal
significant gaps between Facebook's
professed commitment to racial justice
and the company's actions and business
interests the senators want Facebook to
detail by July 10th whether and how the
company will enforce its policies
against hate speech violence incitement
and white supremacy and who at the
company is responsible for doing so so
now they're threatening Nick Clegg the
VP for Global Affairs he said we do not
profit from a we have no incentive to
have hate on our platform we don't like
it our users don't like it but it
doesn't matter
the bottom line is that the Democratic
senators are attempting to basically
find rare posts that get through the
system on Facebook and then use that to
club at Facebook into submission
pushing that has always been the
execrable technology columnist at the
New York Times Kara Swisher who has been
picking on Facebook for a long time
because she loved to see Facebook just
shut down all content she doesn't like
this of course is the same Kara Swisher
who suggested to Susan watch Nikki over
at YouTube and she was very angry that
her own kid was watching my videos and
could could YouTube do anything about
that Kara Swisher is just awful and it
is amazing to watch major media
companies remember the New York Times
was supposed to be a free speech outlet
right that used to be Pro First
Amendment not anymore now they just want
to shut down social media outlets that
they don't like and those social media
outlets have to be brought to heel
reddit by the way is now banning the
donald sub red they're also banned chapo
traphouse and they're doing all of this
because they just don't like the content
right so that they've just decided they
don't like it so that they they made a
new rule change that doesn't even make
any sense they basically said that you
can also talk badly about members of a
quote/unquote majority group which I
suppose means that we can now talk badly
about women in the United States since
women are majority group in the United
States so that's exciting stuff but all
of this is is just incredibly incredibly
terrible and bad for the country all
it's going to lead to is more siloing
and more polarization but that's what
the disintegration is want they want
everything that's integrated that is the
goal okay now quick update I'm Kovac so
you're reading all of these sort of
panicked hemlines about how kovat is
going to kill all of us and I'm failing
to see the evidence that kovat is going
to kill all of us from the death
statistics so the spike in the United
States started approximately two weeks
ago I'm looking at the case spike in the
United States right now the the United
States at coronavirus case spike began
I'm looking at the at the chart the the
diagnosed new cases the spike started
around June 6 June 7 if you look at the
chart that's when it started to uptick
so we're now at the end of June right
you would expect that there would be a
massive uptick in death because that's
what happened at the beginning the
deaths were highly correlative with the
positive test cases instead what you
have seen is a so let's put it this way
they're a they're a grand total on June
6 about 22,000 diagnosed cases in the
United States 20 2009 and June 8 let's
use June 8th because that was kind of a
low point in terms of diagnosed cases
about 18,000 921 diagnosed cases
according to World domineering from
Johns Hopkins 18,000 close to 20,000
diagnosed cases yesterday there were
46,000 diagnosed cases in the United
States and so that means that two and a
half times as many diagnosed cases as
about three weeks ago or close to a
month ago at this point wouldn't you
expect there to be like hmm three times
many deaths two times many deaths one
time as many deaths 50% as many deaths
well instead what's happened is that the
deaths in the United States have
declined radically so in the same period
if you look at the number of deaths on a
daily basis on June 4th are over a
thousand deaths in the United States
from kovin yesterday there were 764
deaths from kovat in the United States
there has not been a massive death spike
the reason there has not been a massive
death spike is because as it turns out
older people are being smart and staying
home and younger people are getting
infected and when younger people get
infected they don't die right they're
not hospitalized for as long so even the
hospitalization statistics are not quite
apples to apples when an older person
was hospitalized with kovat it would get
hospitalized and they would go to the
ICU and then in many cases they would
die when a younger person is
hospitalized they go to the hospital and
many times they leave the hospital so
the number of people who are leaving the
hospital now is much higher so Mike
points this out and of course this means
he's a bad guy but the reality is they
keep saying things like the hospitals
are being overwhelmed we're all in
trouble here
they just ignore the fact that hospital
CEOs are saying no so here is Houston
hospital CEO Mark bloom with with
Houston Methodist and he's one of
several they did their own little press
conference all the heads of the
hospitals in Houston they did their own
little presser and they talked about the
status of ICU beds listen to them talk
about ICU beds they sound like they're
panicked because according to the media
we are on the verge of over running the
ICU beds in places like Houston right
Houston is is literally like ground zero
for the places where they are worried
about ICU beds being overrun if you read
the media here are the actual CEOs of
the hospital talking about whether
they're going to be able to run it
Houston Methodists were somewhere in the
low 90s right now in terms of capacity
of ICU beds but let me put that in
perspective but okay what was our ICU
capacity at one year ago today it was at
95% we are highly experienced at
utilizing our ICU beds for the sickest
of the sick patients day in day out as
I've said and it is completely normal
for us to have ICU capacities that run
in the 80s and 90s that's how all of us
operate hospitals the hospitals operate
this is not the only hospital CEO saying
this doctor dog Doug Lawson with st.
Luke's health another big hospital in
Houston he says we're all concerned
about the spread of the virus that
spread is increasing and incredibly
concerning however our hospitals are ok
and ready to manage the surge
appropriately and effectively Mark
Wallace with Texas Children's Hospital
he says the same thing he says that they
are only at 74% occupancy he says all of
us on this call today we approach this
from a very mission oriented basis we're
gonna be here to fulfill our missions
take care of the patients and families
that need to be taken care of we're
gonna take good care of our employees
and our medical staff he says we have
plenty of capacity to take care of the
children that gets to the doorstep of
Children's Texas Hospital
so all of these hospital CEOs are saying
the same thing which is like we're
concerned about the rising Kovach cases
but we're not panicked and the media is
running around their hair on fire we're
all gonna die look at the spike in cases
the cases are awful look at these
terrible cases we're all gonna die so
Anthony foul - testified before the
Senate yesterday and he said that we're
gonna be in a hundred thousand new cases
a day okay well I have a quest
does that mean that 100 like how many
people are bows are going to die he's
asked this by Elizabeth morning says
there's gonna be a lot of serious death
thank you for that lack of specific
information thank you because guess what
is that there's a lot of serious stuff
right now we're still seeing hundreds of
people a day die from this thing but
here's Anthony factory talking about the
case load the case load is not the real
issue the question is who is getting it
the question is how serious are the
cases that you are seeing in the
hospital the question is are the number
of deaths in ICU is going down are the
number of deaths in hospitals going down
because if not I mean if those things
have gone down then really what we have
done effectively is use the exact
strategy I advocated a couple of months
ago a controlled Avalanche strategy keep
the people or older and more vulnerable
safe and then if young people get it
then young people get it and that's just
how we reach herd immunity there is dr.
Falchi though lamenting the rising cases
when you have an outbreak in one part of
the country even though in other parts
of the country they're doing well they
are vulnerable I made that point very
clearly last week at a press conference
we can't just focus on those areas that
are having the surge it puts the entire
country at risk we are now having
40-plus thousand new cases a day I would
not be surprised if we go up to a
hundred thousand a day if this does not
turn around and so I am very concerned
okay again concern is warranted concern
is relevant you should keep wearing
masks when you're out in public because
again even if young people get sick it
ain't the greatest thing but the idea
that we're about to be overwhelmed in
the healthcare systems I'm not seeing
the data that suggests that we're about
to be overwhelmed that we're in a New
York level overwhelming of the
healthcare system nor am i seeing the
best uptick in deaths that we were
promised this spike began again in early
June it is now July it today's the first
day of July so all of that could change
right I'm only gonna go based on the
evidence if that starts to change if we
start to see massive optics and death
and all of the panic that we're seeing
from the media and from our governor's
maybe that starts to look justified but
if the idea is a bunch of 20-year olds
are getting it and they get like they
can't taste something for three days and
then they're okay that's just one more
person who now cannot pass the disease
on to somebody who is older once they're
done with the disease already so we'll
be back here later today with two
additional hours of content have plenty
more for you where this came from plus
we'll be back here tomorrow with the
conclusion to our broadcast
because Friday I believe we have off for
the wonderful July 4th that we should
all celebrate otherwise we'll see you
here tomorrow I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the bench Bureau show the Ben Shapiro
show is produced by Colton Haas
executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover and
Robert Sterling assistant director Pavel
Whitehouse key technical producer Austin
Stephens playback in media operated by
Nick Sheehan associate producer Katie
Swinton edited by Adam sy events audio
is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair and
makeup is by Anika Geneva the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to Andrew Kleber
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]